this week on world stories Lebanon
freedom of press in a refugee camp
senegal African art on display but first
we head to France where many people are
opposed to the sweeping labor market
reforms and the nuit debout activists
are taking their protests to the streets
chemie makes the first move to tear down
the gates and storm the Odeon the former
primary school teacher wants to occupy
the theatre just like her idols did
during the revolt of 1968 but today the
police winds
excuse it I've ever eaten what I want is
the revolution we need to change our
system and chase away the bosses we need
to dispossess them and decide ourselves
how we want to work and what we want to
do schools have come to light this
message draws big crowds to the
plastered at AP weak-kneed abu's hub
where everyone can discuss and give
speeches there's a great deal of
sympathy for new Dabu in Paris the
movement is tapping into the
disappointment with President Hollande
and his socialist government especially
on the Left where many feel he's
betraying them by adopting conservative
policies citizen its dismal I'm really
disappointed I never had any illusions
but now it's really worse than what I
expected yes it did this fishness in
spite of the disillusion one of the
booze main goals still seems out of
reach an open-ended general strike to
put pressure on the government
another problem for many who are
considering joining me too boo is the
rioting on the fringes of the movement
this rally is no exception I don't think
it's immoral to break things what I
think is evil is too great people like
capitalism does
that's why come e wants to continue the
fight as long as it takes no turning
back to her old life as a teacher the
revolution is still the goal even if it
seems that it will have to wait many of
the streets and bridges and Bangladesh
are in urgent need of repair and that
impairs economic development now with
this hope that projects by Development
Bank's will help improve the
infrastructure
the sheet remover is currently at its
lowest level but it will swell once the
monsoon season begins two years ago the
asian development bank and germany's kfw
group began construction on this bridge
the next nearest bridge is 35 kilometers
away for the 150 thousand residents
getting from one side to another could
often take weeks it is in a continuous
process as you know this country is very
flood prone area many areas are flood
prone and this is challenging but we
believe that these climate resilient
parameter will give some sustainability
to our infrastructure under this project
students in particular are looking
forward to the completion of the bridge
at the end of this year there's only one
secondary school on one side of the
river I mean sighs know what I want to
become a doctor I'm majoring in science
I'm in 10th grade on the first girl in
my class we have to put up with a lot of
hardship to study we have to cross the
river every day so sometimes we're late
to school and in the rainy season it's
even worse there's mud and water
everywhere and our books get wet our
clothes too we face many problems which
make us sad but there's no way out we
know that we have to deal with the
situation in order to study that's why
we need this bridge we needed as soon as
possible ronicky cigar animatronic
pashto grammar school ashy migrant
workers from the region have been
building the bridge the lenders made
sure women were involved in the project
they make up a third of the workforce
gonna cause we're poor people now we're
getting paid and can feed our children
besides the bridge construction the
funding was also used to pave streets at
the market the stands used to sink into
the mud now they've been rebuilt many of
the stands have now been reserved for
women 25 year old Mukti sectors small
business has allowed her to become
financially independent for the first
time
I think we should also work I mean kfw
and ADB we're kind of donors were
working on big infrastructure projects
but then we need better awareness
programs as well so that women have more
access to knowledge more access to the
information what is actually available
for them in the market to access so I
think we could work more on the
awareness issues as well the lack of
infrastructure in Bangladesh has slowed
the country's development it's one of
the most densely populated countries in
the world and without outside assistance
it would struggle to develop
our next report takes us to a Lebanese
refugee camp there are no unbiased media
there but dw's media academy plans to
change that by training young refugees
to become reporters
the shatila refugee camp in Beirut has
housed Palestinian refugees since
nineteen forty nine Syrians and
Palestinians fleeing the war in Syria
have swelled their numbers to 40,000
Sammy Mahmoud and omar ahmed have joined
the DW academy citizen reporters
training program no metal saha felony
here in the shatila refugee camp there's
no press no one reports from the camp
we're taking that job on and reporting
firsthand going on one about the lawar
the site of teenage video journalists is
unusual here Omar has even been detained
by security forces because he didn't
have permission to film the idea of a
free press is a new concept here uh yeah
slogan Khawaja yeah Manas problem it's
hard to film people here hello she's did
I don't many don't want to be filmed for
many of them it's completely new they've
never seen a video journalist before we
need to get permission from the camp
authorities otherwise we're not allowed
to film here was that me 14 teenagers
both male and female have been chosen
for the DW Academy course in cooperation
with a Syrian NGO based in the camp the
training includes research camerawork
editing and storytelling the young
reporters will start a community
platform in November run by refugees for
Refugees a pub and it was supposed to
madam I would like to be the voice of
the young people here right now they're
invisible no one listens to them here in
the camp there was a lot of oppression
many things that people don't get to
hear about haunch I'm still azulon it's
harder for the young female reporters
some areas of the camp are off-limits
without a male escort but they refuse to
be held back I'm nominet how nominal
into the view my love we're filming
interviews with people in the camp we're
trying to find out what people here need
how not offend osuzu wat on sonos on
their inquiries have already borne fruit
after conducting interviews the
reporters learned about some of the
problems in the camp there's not enough
water supply and trash collection needs
improvement so does
curity those are today's headlines from
the new free press in the shatila
refugee camp our final report takes us
to Dakar the capital of Senegal it is
home to duck art one of Africa's leading
international art shows through May
tenth artists there will be portraying
their visions of the African continent
in the Senegalese capital Dakar the
former Palace of Justice has been
converted to house the month-long show
that features contemporary African art
on linear ishida candia a Nigerian
artist living in the u.s. is putting up
his installation from everyday materials
such as cardboard fabric and plastic his
work is an existential reflection of
post-colonial Africa combined with
political and environmental issues it's
a vivid complex creation and materials
that i use our boxes which people throw
away which i cut into pieces and then
also the collections of the slide which
come from different pieces of different
people which i put together to form a
kind of thing so we look like more like
it in net but the idea was I'll connect
our connection our link we had to each
other another question which I'm asking
myself especially with this connection
was to look at what where are we as
Africans where are we now are we still
crawling are we still working or I've
already start standing up or we are
started working the Biennale invited 65
artists what started as a literature
festival 20 years ago in Dakar has
morphed into Africa's largest
Contemporary Art Fair
let me know that I can a la parte the BL
of the car focuses on contemporary art
for both artists in Africa and those in
the Diaspora ok cool so it's important
that it takes place in the continent
okay elizabeth alleged espera nongsa
partner and mark cultural event for the
visual arts no it's 11 market or el
mejor de container for laser vision the
work of Victor at you comin or another
nigerian artist deals with the stark
changes in his country he grew up in a
society largely influenced by mythology
and religion his installation is a kind
of prayer room that recreates the world
of his childhood you know places like
this they are all going estic now you
probably won't find them anymore but I
was lucky enough as a kid to find places
like this where people could go for
prayers good for definition could good
for prophecy you know so that is what
I've created here and the sculpted
paintings are representation of people
that go in there the kind of clothes
they would weird kind of colors that is
vibrant as traditions give way to
technology some old ways of life are
dying out while new lifestyles are still
being defined these are the kinds of
questions about transition posed by the
dark art biennale in Senegal
you